[拍手]
さてへ
皆さんは
ぱーそにっ
夢を感じたことはございますでしょうか
達増時品だって馴染みのない皆さんも多いんじゃないかと思います
しかしこの炭素
実は皆さんの生活をずっと陰で支えている
縁の下の力持ちなんですね
そして同時に歴史的に常に新しい分娩を開く
きっかけにもずっとなってきたんですね
ちょっと備えお話しますと古くは霊能 c 席時代人々は木炭として使い出しました
そして今日まで至ってますまた16世紀以降は例の鉛筆の一シーンですねこれも炭素で
作られました
二重性気に入って
炭素の時代が大きく花開きます
一つはエジソンの塩9度枚目と
人類から夜は克服してくれました
それからタイヤの色真っ黒ですけれども
あの中にはカーボンブラックすぐ入ってまして
強力なタイヤができて自動車の請求を開いてくれました
また dena の発見にも炭素が実は関わっています
そして20世紀の末にカーボンファイバーが登場しまして
宇宙時代を開いてくれました実はこの宇宙時代人類が地球の16系をないして宇宙に
飛び出たこれはまさにわれわれの祖先が自らがって
陸上
ああああああ
動物になるそして今日まで人間として進化をしてきた
これと10日たとも言われているんですね
今この軽くて強いカーボンファイバー
これがあったから宇宙時代がきましたそしてカーボンファイバーは飛行機
さらには自動車まで今使われようとしてましてまさに
天地を駆け巡っておりますこのように炭素は形を変えながら
歴史を
枠刻んで人間の文明開拓に貢献してきました
そして今1mm の100万分の1という非常に極微の
小僧のレベルでぱんさの穴の様式だとかあるいは
ぺー場を制御して生成されるこの後お話しますけど
7巻本っていう新しいターンその登場してですねこれはまさに21世紀の人類の新しい
文明の
ん
開始を安置しているじゃないかとこんな風に言われています
さて私が生まれ育った須坂
子供時代は本当に解雇
養蚕が盛んな町でちょうど今の時期になりますとまちじゅうがこの枚をニュル湯気で
覆われているようなそんな時代でございました
小学校時代はそういった9それまでのキーと産業に代わって
停止作業は実は発達してきまして
郊外って言いますか外れの町外れの桑ノ畑がどんどん
電子産業に買っていったんですねと同時に非常に列し作業で働く技術者の皆さんの瀟洒
な住宅が喉立ち上げがありました
それまでの桑畑がいつしか素晴らしいこの新しい時代の指を感じるような産業に乗って
一平していったんですね
それは子どもの目にもよく理解することができました
新しい産業が街や人々の雰囲気を
一平させていたんです
小学校低学年のころから夏休みやあるいは増やす日になると私の大好きな課題が出され
ました
それは
10研究なんですね
自分逃亡通り研究をして学校に提出したんですけれども残念なるかな
これが消防もらったりあるいは学校も代表作品としてコンクリに出て行くことも実は
ありませんでしたけれども
実験の結果を大きな穂増資にまとめるときはとても
交付を覚えたものでした
私は子供の頃から式お料理
近所の子供たちといつも無料をつくってあそんで歩いてたんですけれどもそういった中
で地域の野山を駆け巡っておりました
科学的好奇心はそういった遊びの中で実は育まれていったように思います
みんなが遊びに宇宙になっている時も私はどちらかと言うと一人客物をつまんだり
今中央弄ったりまた今の時期
雇用を見て感動したりその後
雲がどうしてう関連だろういろんなことを考える
むしろそちらに会社がございました
豊かな自然はいつも大きな感動をくれたように記憶しております
そしてこの街の要素が電子産業っていう新しい作業で一平しているということで新技術
に対する大人たちの期待も非常に高まっていました
そんな背景がございまして1しか自分も新しい環境フェア
技術を身につけてそしてし
社会の発展に役立ちたいこんな夢を抱いていた子どもの時代でした
従ってその延長でごく自然に大学は死守大学工学部に済ませていただきました
信州大学大学修士課程の研究テーマは
をしのこれは常の先生のご指導で
1970年当時でしたんですけれども
全盛を誇っていたシリコン半導体の研究ではなくてですね
気相成長炭素繊維の研究を担当するように c 棟
され
たんですね
自分は半導体研究須坂の街が大きく変貌を遂げていた
停止産業じゃあ興味があったんでその分やと思ってたんですけれども
自分の希望とはちょっと違ったんですねしかしここにはちょっと子供なり学生の時代
でしたけれども打算がございまして大きな池
目だ
感のあるよりも小さないけど恋になりたい
こんな気持ちでございましたそれは子供の頃とういう子どもの頃
遊び半ばとみんなで地区番端によく釣りに行きました時ですね
まさにあざけら払うように
大きな大きな鯉がですねこの部等のツリーとの横を悠々とこう泳いでいる姿
そういう生徒実は思い浮かべておりました
最先端物質のナノカーボンの実用化
これのフロンティアを開拓しているのは実は籠ナノチューブでございまして
世界で活発 d 研究は低下されています
このカーボンなど中部はグラフェンと呼ばれる炭素の六角編み平面の星面をくるっと
丸めた構造
のナノメートルサイズのパンそのつつ気になっております
これは次世代の
半導体あるいは宇宙エレベーターとしても夢がかけられているものでございます
1ミリの100万分の1という非常に小さな国日の鉄の次ぐですね
これを触媒としてメタンなどの炭化水素を予想 send c で熱分解してこの
カボ70部が合成されるんですけどこれは職名気相成長法と呼ばれています
この発明発見はまさに
セレンディピティ食うぜと言いますか予期せぬ結果でございました
1972年に大学院を修了しまして知っあの
大企業に就職したんですけどちょうど生客間の爺な1年経ちまして
とライド授業から c 車ダークの女子として1.5に大学に戻ってくることになり
ました
今度は研究者の駆け出しとして学生たちと日々勉強することになったんですね
とりあえず学生時代やっていた木曽西と炭素星の研究からスタートしようということで
始めたんですけれども
当初実験で得られるのはほとんどが実は大量の進ま黒いススでございまして一緒に後
くれた
所長研究の学生たちとまさに悪戦苦闘の日々でございました
実刑をしていた時このフィーに目の前で反応パイプこれ水素が入ってたんですけど
パーンと大きな音を立てて開く月したいですね色んな事故も何度もございましたそれに
もめげずですねそれでも本当にあの実験がうまくいかずに響くローン
の連続でございました
まだ以上63は若かったからできたのがもしれませんけれども
独身でございまして当時今のような便利なコンビニエンスストアっていうのはござい
ませんで実は母が作ってくれた朝昼
倍音のですねおべんと3つすると学生たちとちょっとつなぐ
ですねおやつを持って毎朝自宅を出たわけです
そして正先生になったということで毎日母
白いワイシャツをアイロンかけをしてそれを着てくるんですけど夕方帰るときはそれと
この襟がですねすすでこう真っ黒になってしまうんですね
やはり当時それをよく知ってたのは母でございました
マイクロしてるんだね避け言われましてそれが実は私とっても大変つらいことでござい
ました
しかしですねう苦しい時間っていうのは誰かが私のために
きっとこれから用意された大成功の税
超じゃないか
苦しい時間というのはこれからくるべきハッピーな時間の
センター回じゃないのかいつもそう思っておりました
そして実は予期しなかったようなまさに夢のような出来事が起こりました
きっとこんな日が突然来るだろうと本当に夢に描いたようなことは実は起きたんですね
ある日
西正規版カーボンファイバーを生やすいたなんですけれどもこれをきれいにするのに
普通は1日
いろいろ71が買って次の日また実験をするわけなんですけれども
たまたまそこにあった茶色いサンドペーパーバー
皆さんよくもこざいく中でお使いになるやつです
ありがとうございましてそれだけ
今起こすたんですねとても綺麗になったんで
大事な次回1日節約できたと喜んでその日もいつものようにできるのは兄
サンドペーパーでこすった牙を入れまして実験をしたんですね
そして翌朝まだ誰も来たおばさんでした
1人敵機して入りまして音声をとって中から希望を出したんですね
そうしたらですねなんとその基盤の上に光り輝く黄色に光り輝いている
カーボンファイバーがしかも長さ数さ1
1差が10ミクロンくらいくれよですねビッ制してたんですね
一つも
黒いススは付いておりませんでした
私は本当に麺を疑いました
そしてて天にも昇るような気分に実は
だったんですね嬉しくて
しかしなぜ突然そうだったのが芸はまったく分からなかったんですけれども
学生たちと同じ味茶色いサンドペーパーで牙を超すて毎日実験を繰り返しまして再検査
よくこのカーボンファイバーの騎馬会の上に成長することができました
小山教授は枝おかー
まあ一つ後論文書く者に後6年はかかるから
まあその妻で行ってこれは小さいそれをやると言ったんですけど
1年後にですね1973年に学会誌にこの論文が掲載されました
おめでとう
徒のの論文が論文に掲載することが決まりました
こういう手紙を学会から受けた時にはですね
本当にあの2度目の天にも昇るような気持ち
なることができましたそしてその一年後
実はフランスへ留学してこの
気相成長炭素制度を構造を解明することになるんですけれども
そのきっかけはですねこの発表した論文がフランスのオルレアン大学のアグネスを
ブラン先生電子顕微鏡の世界的綺麗なんですけどその先生の目に留まって分析と一緒に
やらないかということだったんですね
ああああああ
でフランスの俺ディア出すウスって街に居るレーン大学なんですけどそこへ留学しまし
て
最初の花カ月間一生懸命頑張ったんですね
ならないフランスがもう何とか b つけてそして頑張りました
毎日電子顕微鏡の前に座って朝から晩まで研究をしましたんですけど
くれと言ってですね
いい結果が出なかったんですね散歩路は c 社大学からも持ってきました
フランスでも作ったんですかブンブン作れないですねこれはファースト
パリの近くだったんでなのが良い度の違いじゃないかなってことを言ってたんです
けれども
というかうまく言えませんでした
そして8か月だった12月のクレイ
マトリョーたちはみんなですね
クリスマス休暇ですねこれでみんな
地中海の方へ
旅行に行ったりあるいはクリスマス強化見た楽しいでたんですけど私は一人この時と
ばかりですね
レジ顕微鏡が独占できるんで愛知県武侠シティネット貼りをしてそしてそこで元気を
続けたわけです
そしたら本当に大発見が起きたんですねサンドペーパー由来の後首の
小さな鉄の粒子が炭素星を成長させることを発見したんです
この時も本当に3回目の天にも昇るような気持ちに実は
なりましたまさに神さんもからのクリスマスプレゼントでございました
大発見興奮した様子で私は自分の日記帳に書いた記憶がございます
まさにいつもながらチャンスの女神は準備を整えたものに微笑みかける
その時し1日頃の努力が神様
しっかり見ててくださったな思いました
これが後のカーボンなど中部の量作法の開拓につながるわけです
地下も大変驚くことに反応韓中の空感じですね
鉄道粒子が浮いている間にかぼなどチューブを成長させるということを八景発明いたし
ましてこれが1987年に1本特許として認められることができました
これが高
乳のか本など十分の量産法になっているんです
ボタンの努力は一つもない成功はあきらめずに夢に向かって努力することだといつも
各種しておりますこして1988年からもの多層化本など中として量産が閉じ
共同研究していた企業の中で始まります
そして当時1980年の後半ですけれども
企業の中でで寿命電池の研究は進んでましてそこにこれを使うと非常に良いキットせが
出るということで今日まで実はリチウムイオンで自分の際よくお使いでございます携帯
ではノートパソコン
それの発展をずっと陰である支えてきた
材料なんですね
でこの職場へ気相成長法をよるとですねまの構造が厚膜制御できるんですね
それで
より安全なか本など中部の構造を目指してこれは
で際政府などというふうに国際的な呼ばれてまして
安全なの構造を作り出してそれを使っていこうということで安全なイノベーションを
目指して今世界的に著名ヘッジが撤回されているものでございます冒頭下申し上げば
したナノカーボンとはですね7メーターのレベルで1ミリの100万分の1ですけれど
も
何その構造や携帯を制御して作るそういった新しい構造を持ったたその構造体です
この概念は刺繍大学で生まれた概念で今世界的に使われております
プラ連の発見で
1996年ノーベル化学賞を受賞されたハリー黒と先生は19世紀は別
20世紀はシビコ20世紀はパスの性器等こういうふうにおっしゃってましたがこの
ようなナノカーボンが20世紀をひらっ
いう風にまた1まあ覚醒しておりますまた
マサチューセッツ工科大学アメリカですがそこのブレセロハン先生
これはあのカーボンの世界的だけいで
米国の自由述べてあるあるいはかぶる賞を受賞された方なんですけれども
この玄人先生とどれセロハン先生
お二人とも最近天に召されまして
まさにいえば伝説になってしまったお二方なんですけれども
2人ともカーボンの知性ということは言えると思います
私は2人と
多くの挙動京急を展開していきまして
この抱いた2人の科学者の研究者だましっていうものをぜひですね
若い研究者に伝えたい
それはどんなことかと申し上げますと黒と先生は自らを
科学の伝道師っていうふうに超して研究者の大切な点は常に好奇心を持ち続けることだ
と説いていましたあたビリー先生は現役の科学者として論文執筆のペンを取りながら
天国いい旅だったよ
ような形でございまして彼女は86歳でございました
普段の努力こそ研究者では不可欠だということを身を以て示された方なんですね
そしてこの二人に共通する研究者魂がございました
それはをの love るぽパティということなんですね名声を求めず無心で記憶科学
に向き合う
この姿勢なんです
この際に対する真摯な姿勢こそ何か新しいものを生み出すさんスイング new を
乱す
目になると2人は常におっしゃってたんですね
カーカーますます高度化する時代こういった各との向き合い方
これは今後ますます重要になってくるでしょう
さて
カモなど厨房先ほど申し上げた細いチューブですけどこれを束ねて作るバイヤーは人口
送電線として応用が期待されています
大変注目されているんですね世界はすでに
情報通信ネットワークが結ばれていますが
てぃんびら会で予測される世界電力もね
ああああああ
そう容易じゃないですね何故かと申しますと
送電西洋になる動画とても
それだけも遅延がないですね超しますとカーボンナノチューブで作った銅線送電線って
いうのは非常に期待されているんですね
これができますと日本含めたまず
ユーラシア送電もっていうのがどうもう
できるそういう方向で言えば世界
まぁ一生懸命頑張ってるんですねでこの
混成のナノカーボンを使ったりチューブでじゃあさらに性能を強化することができる
でしょう
そうすると私たちは携帯デーヴァでパソコンである岩端保でも
れっ子の存在を忘れて使うことができる時代が来るでしょう
また電気自動車の技術もさらに家族されるでしょう
このらのカーボンで製造に必要な炭素っていうのは今まで石油とかセクターが使われて
ましたけどこれからは空気中の二酸化炭素から
タンスを遊離して何かを作ろうという研究が今住んでいるんですね
これが成功しますと地球の温暖化の影響である
井坂炭素
どんどん減らすことができるそのように期待されているわけでございます
私の現金のツールは少年時代を過ごした恐竜須坂の湯たから自然でした
自然の中で培った関係の好奇心が
大きな夢を育てそして私自身の研究のエネルギー源となりました
疑似世紀の地球の環境保全と持続可能性はまさに
なの交番でよるイノベーションの創出にかかっておりそれによってくると先生が
おっしゃったようなまさに
炭素の性器が来ると
を隠ししています
これからもですね若江研究者そして学生しょくんとともにですね
このナノカーボンイノベーション目指して搭載して参りたいと思います
決して諦めずねばエヴァネバーネバー and never give up あきらめ
ないぞと
この姿勢で
進めてまいりたいと思っております
どうご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]